okay so what about your childhood what's
like a favorite Christmas memory oh
favorite Christmas memory I remember one
year because of me it was my bright idea
I'm the creative in the family and I put
together I was like let's have a family
um um talent show yes and so I thought I
was going to win because you know I'm
the talent of the family and I sang um
Angel by um uh Ang need God true blank
thanks and then my uncles came in and
they blew the roof off the house with um
the Temptation song Oh which one um it's
Merry Christmas happy cuz I have an
uncle with the why can't I think of
songs today say that again Silent Night
yes Silent Night no one's ever heard of
it no right that's a it's new it's a new
song apparently so they kic they killed
it they totally stole the show and it's
literally we talk about it to this day I
mean this was when I I was 12 I'm 53
we're still talking about this moment
wait I totally thought you meant you did
this as an adult and you were like and
you were like I wanted everyone to do a
talent show cuz I was going to win and I
was like I was just picturing you at
like 35 just like I've got my Nita Baker
okay I love it it's even it would have
been better if you would have been 35 so
what's one of your favorite Christmas
Memories with your son oh God he's older
now but like no he's grown now but I
love when they're little bits you know
when they're little little little bit
because but you know that my he's so
grown now and that was I produced that
play on Broadway
J yeah that's so awesome to see his mama
killing it yeah he was so proud he
really was proud it is I have the young
age still so it is kind of still fun F
because you know it's you know I think
we have more fun than they do like
putting the toys together the night
before but my son was funny he liked
what he liked so he would pick like two
or three things I swear I think I picked
the wrong baby up at the hospital
but he would pick like four toys and
that's all he wanted and I would buy him
like 12 thinking he wants this he wants
this this is me with my children heur
did he he hurt my feelings because I
would watch him open the gifts and he
would be
like and he would get those four gifts
that he asked for grab those up and go
in his room and all the other stuff I
bought is just sitting outside and I can
be this I can be this my kids don't even
open them
Mall there's not that many like you know
what I'm saying they will literally open
once they find something they like they
just go play with and I'm like I'm sorry
I spent a lot of time doing this exactly
yes like these kids they're so
privileged I'm like what yeah they do
not know what it's like Anyway let's and
we worked hard for that but whatever uh
let's get to a there's a lot of therapy
here
[Music]
needed
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home